oh very high rated FM
okay I'll play it London
and yeah let's try and treat this
somewhat seriously
got a Mainline 95
I used to play Bishop G3
this is already like preferable for like
King E7 is the best move
so if blocks I take and the bishop is
stunned or if blocks I take on F7 wait a
minute
yeah taking enough Saturn
a typical London tactic
Queen A5 I have Knight C3
oh wait a minute it's not so simple
though
because this move
wait what's happening
I Bishop D3
Queen H5
first
I'm actually not sure about this
Jack
yeah now there's an E5 I believe
now at least The Bishop's not hanging if
Knight takes I take here first
I think I just take on F6
take
and just castling
but then no that should be fine
and then Queen E2
whatever it takes back when you two
defends the bishop
got a little bit tricky oh there's still
C4 in the end
ah
am I losing a piece
F3
what's happening
I I have maybe take some Bishop E8
but I don't know my Bishop's coming out
alive
uh
I mean I could take on C4
maybe A4 first
a six take Bishop E8 Rook Cafe it
doesn't work
okay I'm down going down the piece have
three pawns for it
what a weird start to the game I thought
I trapped my opponent I somehow got
counter trapped
Bishop t7
and let's play C3
looks somewhat solid
pawns are not really complementing the
bishop but The Bishop's outside the pawn
chain
Queen D1
not the happiest move
gotta move a bit quicker
E4 may be coming
controlling the center I still have all
eight Pawns
if he wants to come to H6
interesting
okay
throw in this move
still on invade H6
hmm
I see fours maybe coming
B3 take
not sure
play B3 taking too long there
ideas to play C4 of ticks I have this
move hitting multiple things
I'm not sure if it works though
making block think
I mean if I get this Pawn to E6 I have
F4 F5 in the end
the dream is to get pawns like this and
a bishop on E5
yeah Queen side down to defending G7 so
I can't take the pawn
now I can't play this immediately
because Queen C5 wins the bishop
so I have to start with King age of Y
Man
F5 is coming soon
up on time
um
what's happening
Queen is still stuck
let's move
threading this and this
there we go
oh
he
'll promote tonight with fork
I was a victim of this yesterday
actually my last game on stream
yesterday
oh what a fun way to end the game
oh
okay
that was uh what was that that was a
London emotional roller coaster
I posted a video earlier which was a
ponziani emotional rollercoaster
but I think this game was even more
emotional
like so many ups and downs I'm sure the
engine graph will be
maybe inspiration for like a theme park
ride
let's look at this engine graph I was
never like so much worse I was only like
clearly worse but not losing worse
opponent had Knight takes E4 wow
because the app Pawn's pinned
tactics are important
okay that was a fun game
um what should I do wrong
so Knight F7 is the best move this is a
nice London trap happened once in Master
Level game or Master Level play
um
Bishop D7 can also be thrown in
but it got weirdly tricky 94.
ah I can just take and black has no time
to win C3
yeah takes takes
oh I'm just meeting here Queen F3
because it's not Chuck
Queen F3 and King G8 Queen f8 mates if
here
the queen will
kind of zigzag and eventually take you
six
okay nice uh opening lesson there
if this goes on YouTube hope you enjoyed
this don't forget to subscribe follow on
Twitch
or subscribe on Twitch